well I've studied over the years the the
the problem of aid effectiveness and how
foreign aid has become a kind of
permanent fixture in so many developing
countries and the ones where it's most
egregious is really the countries where
taxation and overall domestic revenues
how much money the country collects in
revenues on its own is in the low double
digits for example especially in Africa
but also in Cambodia and as a result is
not able to finance its needs and so
brings in foreign aid to do that which
is the purpose of foreign aid but you
see if that continues forever then it
means the country is not really
collecting the resources needed for its
national development when you see
corruption being equal to the foreign
aid in magnitude you start wondering
what is exactly going on in the minds of
leaders and why they're not collecting
taxes and I've argued that there's a
relationship between taxation and
accountability especially if you're
trying to have a democracy because if
you're not taxing people then they're
not entitled to representation in your
mind or they don't pay your salary and
therefore not listening to them as a
result of all this so the the link
between taxation and accountability is
broken and democracy as a result is
heard which I don't think is good in the
long term for sustainable development
and growth I think the volume of trade
for countries that are able to get into
the global Commons by by by
participating in the in global trade
really means a lot to them I mean
Cambodia for example at one point
exported three billion dollars worth of
garments per year it received at most 1
billion dollars worth of foreign aid the
3 billion dollars worth of garments
represented 350,000 jobs direct jobs
more than a million people benefited as
a result so this is far more meaningful
and far more sustainable I would argue
than foreign aid which is often times
comes as a hand
that causes problems like corruption and
and conflict over the ADA itself between
an among agencies so trade is essential
for I would argue the the sustainable
development of countries